- Du musst die Schuhe nicht ausziehen.
Komm rein! Der Flur ist so kalt.
- Danke.
- Was kann ich für dich tun?
- Ist Nico da?
- Ja sicher … Nico?
Er wird sicher gleich kommen.
- Vielen Dank, aber ich suche
nur mein Portemonnaie.
Ich glaube, Nico hat es noch. Ich habe
es in die schwarze Tasche gesteckt.
- Wir werden es sicher finden.
Aber erzähl mal: Woher kommst du?
Du kommst nicht aus Deutschland, oder?
- Nein, ich komme aus Syrien und lebe
seit fast einem Jahr in Deutschland.
- Bist du alleine in Deutschland?
- Nein, ich bin mit meinen Eltern hier.
- Und hast du Geschwister?
- Ja, ich habe zwei ältere Brüder.
Die leben in Hamburg.
- Und deine Großeltern?
- Meine Großeltern leben noch in Syrien.
- Das braune Portemonnaie
gehört dir, oder?
- Ja. Danke!